i give her the respect she deserves i
pop my head up and i keep walking
straight
because i don't want to feel creepy and
i don't want her to feel creepy
it's natural i mean that's what a tittie
is for to be sucks i mean it's really
there for you know the baby so i don't
see why people complain about you
breastfeeding
i see it all the time that people get
pissed off but now if i see a grown man
sucking a titty in public i kind of got
a problem with that
but on the other hand there's a lot of
money unless unless he unless he got an
issue where he can't eat whole food then
i'm okay with it
that's the next thing like service dogs
that's the next thing service dog you
know people have service dogs uh-huh one
day somebody's gonna say you know what
because my mom
fed me and i depend on that
i need to suck titties and [ __ ]
is the day
there's people who do like a baby thing
have you seen that like there's people
who like pretending they're babies
i saw this video of a girl who's like
20s in a diaper she has a big crib in
her room her boyfriend pretends he like
changes her diaper that's that's that's
sick crazy i've seen it i've seen kids
like that's too old to be sucking
titties like you ever seen a video with
a little boy about seven years old
sucking a mama titty with the little
brother i sucked a pacifier until i was
six i was on my way to being a little
dick sucker but my mother stopped that
you understand me when you're like a
pacifier at six your future is bleak you
follow him saying to you this show the
church of what's happening now is
brought to you by lending tree are you
looking to buy a house
you know what i'm saying you put your
little application in the bank they work
you over did you know that depending on
where you get your mortgage you could
save
20 000 or more but 80 of people only get
one mortgage offer and if you just go to
your bank chances are you'll get ripped
off
screwed lendingtree doesn't want that to
happen
are you sure you want the best deal find
out what you can save today at
lendingtree.com church again that's
lendingtree.com
church number one
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country uh cooking together
builds strong family bonds research
shows
that blue aprons
families cook nearly three times more
often together let me tell you about the
upcoming meals you got yourself a little
basil pesto chicken
sauteed shrimp and green beans whole
grain pasta and it goes on and onward
what i'm gonna do for you is this
check out this week's menu and get your
three first meals for free with free
shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey again that's blueapron.com joy i'm
gonna give you three meals
with shipping sent to your house recipe
card you're gonna have a party with mama
all right again go to blueapron.com
mr churchill what's happening now
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're gonna take mrs pat back to old
school
when she was walking this [ __ ] with hot
pants son
saying what
what year is this lee 82 my girl oh yeah
i probably didn't have an 80s
[ __ ] a couple years after that i was
somebody mama [ __ ]
that's that disco music
someone don't hold your time someone to
treat you right oh [ __ ]
friend of mine here we go here we go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] shake that ass [ __ ] suckers it's
the church and what's happening now
monday august 7th
or wednesday august 9th the day the
devil was buried insane get it hit it
that's my birthday mule kick it up kick
it lee
oh [ __ ]
ah
the friend of mine
anytime
i'll sound awesome
that's a [ __ ] jam dog church of
what's happening now coming at you it's
a beautiful day to be alive miss pat is
in the house what's up the [ __ ]
flying jew is in the house hello miss
pat's youngest beautifulest daughter's
in the house
she's the oldest that's my medicaid baby
okay she's beautiful yeah what does that
mean
she was born on medicaid okay
yo texas paid for her to get out of me
thanks to you paying your taxes they was
able to pull out with a nice fee
now when you had the baby they put you
in a nice hospital too uh i when you
always go poor people always go to the
po people hospital in the community
hospital or something
and medicaid well that's not like the
baby's coming out of you
and you walk into like beverly hills
hospital with a bunch of white people
they'll still deliver your baby
they can't believe you look at them they
like oh you belong down the street it
was 86 they probably would have but you
know i couldn't get to beverly hills
actually when i went in labor with her
you know i had at 14
and when they pulled up when i when i
called the ambulance i lived in the hood
in vine city and my sister went and
called 9-1-1 and she lied and said the
baby was coming out but the ambulance
was up the street picking up another
dude who just got stabbed so they ran
down to my house with this [ __ ] in the
back of the car and they coming to get
me and the baby ain't coming out so my
mom was like you're going to take your
anyway so i'm in the ambulance with
another dude they've been stabbed in the
shoulder oh my god it's like an uber
pool
that's terrible and you're 14.
no i was like mama you calling me she's
like you can handle that [ __ ] i got time
for that i'll come pick you up so it was
me i'm pregnant with her and some random
drunk dude in the back of the ambulance
that who's been stabbed
this pat what are you 40 39 i'm 45.
and she's 31. what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do when you hit 50. you're gonna
wake up that day and go jesus christ
that's what i did
the day i woke up when i turned 50 i was
like jesus christ
i was in an ambulance you're giving me
birth
no no i don't feel low either that's not
the point
point is that one at one time in your
life
you know i i've done it i've done it a
thousand times i've been in those
situations you know you you started
going to meetings
you shot across some pretty high-powered
people in the middle of [ __ ]
meeting
while you're telling your stories you
know and they're offering you salsa
water
or a bagel
you know
and i say i don't eat that [ __ ] and
you're looking at them thinking
these [ __ ] have no idea what
i've really seen
yeah you ever get that feeling sometimes
you ever walk into a room and
everybody's [ __ ] really nice
and they all have watches on and purses
and [ __ ]
you know like 20 years ago me and my
dogs would have shot these [ __ ]
including that turkey on the table
yeah
on the table you know i'm reading this
book that bob lalingas gave me the three
lives of jimmy page
and it's like i had three [ __ ] lives
four lives
and so did you yeah rabbit i'm sorry
yeah rabbit
and patricia then miss pat yeah pretty
much
you have a bunch of we have and then you
look back like one day you're doing
something and it makes you reflect it
makes you think of that life
and you have like an anxiety attack you
know what really gets me when i look
back sometimes like to me my kids i have
a 19 and a 17 year old at the house and
i just think they're so ungrateful like
how they weigh [ __ ] and they waste the
food and [ __ ] and you know they oh mama
let me let me get your debit card i
could have never asked my mom for a
[ __ ] whole phone stuff she just
stabbed my [ __ ] ass and like we
grew up we grew up eating like the
chicken back and chicken ass i don't
know if you ate chicken ass but it's
like it's like the po [ __ ] nuggets
little ass to hang out the back of the
chicken back is this little inch of it
yeah the look
no where i come from that was that was
po people chicken nuggets
so we grew up eating chicken ass where
my kids is they just so [ __ ] wasteful
and that [ __ ] it pisses me off
it pisses me off so bad because i was
like you [ __ ] are waste stuff
when i grew up eating i grew up thinking
the only part of the chicken was a
chicken back in the chicken eggs because
the wing and legs went to other people
grown people we got the [ __ ] back you
know no [ __ ] meat on the back
you suck them bones and by the time you
eat that little meat hanging off that
ass and then when you grow up and
realize you ate a lot of chicken ass you
get pissed the [ __ ] out i was like as
many food stamps we got why the [ __ ] are
we eating chicken ass
chicken ass is good until you know his
chicken ass
then you like i ate chicken ass
for years that's the craziest like the
the part for me that's hardest to under
like comprehend when you say you had a
kid at 14
like like all right yeah how do you
think about
providing any like food or anything for
a kid when you're like at 14 i was
excited to be
making 100 bucks a week at like a
grocery store or something like that
i think when you have i think as a when
you have a kid and you're in a situation
like well with me when i had that kid
that young my survival move just kicked
in you know like it's like if you said
you just just you you get you you you
you you you a judge
like even if you're a young 14 year old
boy who get kicked out on the street by
your parents you got it's your survivor
skill kicked in if you if you if if not
you're gonna [ __ ] die so not only did
i have me to feed i had a [ __ ] child
to feed which was hard i mean a can of
milk back in those days was four dollars
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is really high now i
couldn't even afford four dollars so i
would go to the local convenience store
i mean the little store on the corner
and steal [ __ ] milk
because i was you know
i was too young to get a job
so there's like you know when i had my
my second child at 15 i was like where's
your work permit so i would take them on
interviews he'll [ __ ] meet
ashley and nikhil that's my [ __ ] work
for me give a [ __ ] job but i wasn't old
enough
so you know that's how the drug thing
came along
was it drugstore
hell no i sold drugs no i never did
drugs i never smoked drink or anything
but your survival move kick in so that's
that's how i was able to you know to
take care of the kids plus i didn't want
them to i didn't want them to be [ __ ]
up like i was
i'm just thinking like at 14 i think
what that's eighth grade ninth grade
eighth well you know back then it was no
middle school so you went straight from
elementary to high school
so i was in elementary school with a
boyfriend with a car and you know i'm
not thinking i'm naive i'm thinking it's
the coolest [ __ ] in the world i'm like
y'all hoes playing with these boys on
bikes my boyfriend got caught my
boyfriend
you ride by the playground hey
y'all like y'all some lame [ __ ] your
boyfriend got a huffy my boyfriend got a
chevy with no with no uh flow board in
the [ __ ] a boom box on the back
seat he you know i thought that was the
life
well i gotta because that back then
black people had just calmed down from
towing the boom box so they was no
longer told them they was putting them
on the back seat or they caught
something they can help if you couldn't
afford the boom you put the [ __ ]
the boom box on your back seat so my
boyfriend had a call y'all boyfriend had
a [ __ ] huffy i thought it was cool
when i was in this eighth
or seventh grade
there was a kid in my class that knocked
up a chick
and he was gonna [ __ ] live with it in
the seventh grade juan soto was his name
he was 13 going on thirty five did she
keep it
you know what he never came back to
school well he couldn't he probably had
to go [ __ ] yeah
no he got a job i never ever ever heard
from him or saw him again
but i always thought about him like what
he was in love with this girl they were
like childhood and they would walk home
together i think she he was
he was in the seventh grade she was in
the eighth grade but he was like 13. he
had gotten left back because it was
english when he came from cuba
so
but to [ __ ] uh
commit to a home at 13 like that's it
it's man it was it was [ __ ] hard
it's such a [ __ ] you know you said
something you go it's like listen when
my mother died at 15.
i had to make choices i could have lived
with family in california or miami
but i was already two years in this
[ __ ] high school my [ __ ] was
just starting to get together
so i moved in with a family man
and they provided electricity for me and
a bed and food
but i had to do my own thing and i
thought my mom left social security and
there was no prudential insurance and
none of that [ __ ] no no i had to get a
job and i learned
and i went without i got into drugs you
know i made my own bed you know
but it was very i think about it now how
i still remember being 17 and own a
bookie
800 bucks and it's tuesday
and you got to give it to him on
thursday
i look back a lot too and wonder how the
[ __ ] did i survive me too you know
especially being shot and being through
all the [ __ ] that i wanted i was
never shot i was just hunted
they just never got me
they were hunting for me they just never
got me
i mean you and this is a girl so you
really don't expect girl to go through
girls to go through all that [ __ ]
you know i was in a very beast
relationship i'm here i am uh
15 with two kids and this man like 23
years old married with a wife at home
with his second baby and i'm uh well he
just had his second baby and i'm on i'm
on i'm on his fourth baby because i'm
having my son behind so you know it was
[ __ ] rough it was some i looked back
sometime and it scared the [ __ ] out of
me
honestly
yeah like writing this book brought up
so much [ __ ] that i'm locked out it
sucks decked on it right now sucks dick
though
i think sucking [ __ ] a little bit
better
oh my god [ __ ] did i tell you what
happened i had three chapters two
chapters ready to go i had one more
for the [ __ ] thing you got to give
them and the website went out of
business
and i didn't say it i didn't back it up
on cloud
so i waited until i i just hired a dude
i went and got a [ __ ] pro-mech
and i went to work and every day i do a
thousand words
you're writing one now a thousand words
i gotta have this done by the end of
august at least three chapters for the
[ __ ] proposal man
this has taken me three [ __ ] years
but it's basically because
the chapter he wants me to write
is
is hell
is hell it's from 79 to 85. those are my
hell years i got a thousand good stories
and i got a thousand bad stories
yeah but i thought i never had a thought
think about it again
and those feelings yes those feelings
you know what because i had a uh a lady
by the name of janine amber wrote it
with me what she did out of writing i
told the story i you know i like being
honest i have to give her credit she did
a [ __ ] remarkable job with helping me
write this you know helping me write
this book but um
uh it just it brought up so much [ __ ]
that i i didn't talk about it brought up
so much feeling that i had buried it i
mean it was so many it was so many times
we had to stop the interview and we
would cry together
like when i got into the stories um of
with the kid's father and
you know the biggest issue that i
realize is like wow i'm 15
pregnant with two kids i mean you got
two kids by a married man
and society don't give a [ __ ]
you they literally allowed this grown
ass man to come to the hospital and sign
my kids birth certificate who's eight
years older than me nobody ever
questioned it nobody
and you know what what gets me now i'm
45 and i say to myself [ __ ] if i was a
white girl what that [ __ ] had happened
i truly believe that [ __ ] would
still be in jail
it was a different time it was a
different time it's a different place
this country
has changed let me tell you it is so
much well
you can say that it has changed a lot
even for the black community but i still
think that
i mean i'm one of those lost calls you
don't hear a lot about what black women
go through in you know in the ghetto
like with teen pregnancy and stuff like
that they don't give a [ __ ] about people
like me people like me were supposed to
you know
we never rise to the top i think that's
how they kind of see it
so i think that's why people are so
shocked they're like you had two [ __ ]
kids at 15 and you didn't use drugs and
you're this and your dad
i mean i'm like come on even even the
hospital in the black community should
have done something when i had that
first kid by their body
what do you think happened after you had
the first child if the child was three
months old
you had thought about what's happened
your frame of mind is a little different
if you picked up the phone and down
9-1-1
let me ask you what do you think would
have happened what year was this 1986.
what do you think would have happened
well
i mean i'm 14 so i supposed to have a
parent that was supposed to be taking
care of me for for once and it was a
caseworker involved that wanted my mama
to do something but she didn't do [ __ ]
now
times have changed a lot now where the
the the
the states would step in and say now
[ __ ] this ain't going down i mean right
somebody right he's [ __ ] 50 and
you're 20 and you're 18.
yeah
is that the grandpa yeah
exactly so i'm 14 and got a baby by a 21
year old man that is [ __ ] ridiculous
can i ask you and because there's
obviously racism in the world
but is it a racism thing or do you think
it's a money issue i think it's a
society issue i don't think it's right i
don't think it's racism i just think
it's you know like it's like it's like
you can meet a white person that don't
know what the [ __ ] go on on the other
side of the track with other people
other than people that look like them
and they don't want to know and they
don't want to know but i'm going to tell
you something just to put and i'm not
protecting the white man but i got to
state my case here if i'm going to speak
up yeah in 1983 and i've told you this
story i was a 20 year old kid and i got
a job in the warehouse
that's the best i could do 10 an hour
you stock pipe
electrical thing and we had to load
three trucks
and there was a dude that was maybe at
the time
38 to 40.
his wife was 16
and she would ride in the truck with her
she was a scared little [ __ ] white
girl
and you know i worked with him for a
couple months and one day i had to go on
a delivery when i'm gonna ask them
how is this and it goes i i the parents
gave it to me
they signed the rover we have a child
together
this [ __ ] was 40 she was barely
16 or 15 man
that is so every and everybody on this
job site
knew the situation
but they also knew that this dude just
did like 12 years in prison and just got
out like four years earlier
for like murder or something and the guy
had a heart of gold
that was his only flaw like he had a
hard dick
when you talk to him you could see the
[ __ ] that he wasn't all there
you could see that he probably got hit
in the head with a kid with a rock or
you played football well yeah you know
somebody no but listen but nobody
investigate to see if somebody really
gave him that 16 year old girl
never he worked there for years
even after i quit i was still friends
with the people there because i did
drugs with them bought drugs with them
and we would always talk about them
and he was solid he was on time he did
his delivery so nobody asked questions
most child molesters are solid and on
time until you say 1970 something
led zeppelin jimmy page
traveled with a 14 year old girl across
the country it was a runaway and [ __ ]
her for years
till today they they're saying that they
should have charged them with statutory
rape
there's a thousand situations in this
country
you know thousands it's [ __ ] crazy
what the and some people go to jail
and some people [ __ ] well it's it's a
lot better now because if you tried this
[ __ ] today yeah i mean look at that
kelly he got he tried they bout to lock
his ass up for 18 yards what did he do
what is going he got a coat somewhere
speaking of r kelly the cops and comedy
[ __ ]
kelly kelly's spirits somewhere
uh r kelly them picked up they okay
let's do the whole biography of heart
kelly here because i want to be part of
the black community tonight i just said
my community
i just sent my 23 and over package i'm
waiting for the results
you want to know if you need to be mad
at r kelly and they tell you and they
tell you what you're going to die from
damn
they do the dna thing and they can be
cardiovascular or diabetes oh why do you
want to know that because what the [ __ ]
dog i really want to know the origin of
who the [ __ ] i am
because some dude about two years ago
[ __ ] with my head
he said he did a trace and i'm related
to a sicilian lieutenant
in sicily in 19 [ __ ] 10 and i
literally do a picture and i do look
like i could be his nephew
but look at my father i look like him i
look like my mother i look at when i was
when i was a kid
i saw a picture of my mother's family
but in those days
uh their family
is really what you call to the yo in
cuba
which means they have part indian blood
in
columbus went to cuba he killed a bunch
of indians
but some of them lived and [ __ ] some
white cubans
and the white humans [ __ ] some black
slaves wonderful when you mix it really
so cuba's just one big mix
i want black people too
everybody is one big meme you don't mean
dog how many homies i'm as honest as i
can
when the first time i saw a picture of
my sister
like i didn't remember my sister when i
left cuba
but when i was like six my mother came
home running i got school pictures from
cuba your sister
take a look and i saw that dark skin i
was like
i got questions but i ain't gonna ask
them
i never said no
you know what i have a brother who's we
know this is biracial but we supposed to
have a saying daddy and my brother is
[ __ ] blacker than me headsets
my daddy was blacking in these headsets
but my brother is [ __ ] biracial as
hell i mean you can tell he's [ __ ]
everybody when i show you his baby
picture everybody i think he's a white
little girl really yes but
nobody ever say you know good damn well
that's when your [ __ ] daddy
is there stigma and like i'm like among
black people like
with skin color because well
light-skinned brothers remember pierre
that was his claim yeah who likes girls
being a light skinned brother and [ __ ]
well well light skinned brother was
really popular i think dog skin is right
now everybody liked the dog skin victory
robbers what's his name robbie's
idris elba
yeah we they like them like israel
that's like a 10-pointer
i thought you tried to say an opera
singer i gotta tell you this story
because you ain't gonna believe this
what so i'm six i see the picture of my
sister she's a little dark-skinned
my godmother's dark
who was my santoria godmother and she
pretty much i was i lived at a house
you know she would cut a chicken and
cook it up
you know and orlando sepeda was a famous
baseball player so i was like man some
of these cubans are black you know all
right [ __ ] it i'll live with it
we get to miami one time
and again my mother comes to the hotel
she goes look at the picture of our
family
look at our cousins and she opened up
that [ __ ] portrait
and there was 30 it looked like an nba
basketball team
with one little white trainer
in the corner and i told her i said
listen
i don't know what [ __ ] voodoo you're
trying to play on me that ain't my
[ __ ] family
so you're your mom was like i was i was
i must have been eight we were in miami
we were at my godmother's house
it was like seven in the morning she was
always cute cooper's got dark skin but
at that time i didn't know for sure i'm
like what you thinking there was black
people i'm looking at a picture of my
sister she's dark skinned i'm looking at
my mother i'm looking at my dad am i
adopted and you know what i'm saying
like something ain't right here that my
sister's [ __ ] black and i didn't want
to i knew how kids they come out of the
[ __ ] i knew all that [ __ ] but i didn't
have the balls to ask so i lived with
that little stigma for two years that
okay i got a black sister
that's just the way life is okay now one
time it crossed your mind maybe your
mama [ __ ] was on board that day i have
no [ __ ] idea so
now she shows me this [ __ ] in the 70s
they would send you these pictures in
like a portrait style and you'd open
them up when i look they look at your
cousins and i saw all them black people
i looked like i said listen i know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about these are
not my cousins
miss pat she threw a beat on me
like left right left right left right
okay
please
rip the shirt off me yeah like to go in
the [ __ ] room and don't come out
that's your family when you accept it
come out of the room what do you think
you're [ __ ] white you little piece of
[ __ ]
she just went off you got black [ __ ]
skin
look at your father look at your [ __ ]
sister stupid
and after that beating [ __ ] i'm black
welcome to the other side
was you at the soul food restaurant that
got kicked shot up today no you know
what man i don't need soul food out here
i gave up
i i haven't gotten any good soul food in
california you're not gonna get it down
and it's very overpriced
everything out here is damn overpriced
let me tell you something there's a
little joint
that they've turned they've converted
four or five times
lee used to always go to a joints called
skinny kitchen when lee used to go to
first started going skinny kitchen there
was a black joint next to it do you not
remember lee
you took me there i'm pretty sure
remember
we had three pieces of chicken listen
miss pet three pieces of chicken and two
side orders thirty-six dollars
thirty-six dollars listen to really
looked at each other i don't listen i
don't give a [ __ ] i know you're trying
to make a living but when you leave
there you go the chicken was fantastic
but you think about the receipt you go
30 dollars it was two plates was 30
million 36 and they were
two-piece chip chicken dinners like with
two pieces of chicken and macaroni and
cheese or a little piece of [ __ ] corn
so that place closed down of course then
across the street on the same side 50
yards up there used to be a hot dog
stand
they got lines of black people standing
out there in north hollywood right
[ __ ] you to my pink
no no no no right now if you go to north
hollywood three blocks from here that
main street
there's a movie theater lemley
right next to lindley there's a little
[ __ ] place that has 15 tables at the
diner it was closed forever it's a dine
that's closed forever and they got
tremendous [ __ ] fried chicken in
there
they open they open right now until 10
but miss pat i gotta tell you something
my wife brought it home my wife's from
the south we ate it we had a good time
and at the end my wife goes how much do
you think that cost me
like maybe 28
boom 50 bucks
we both because we're both leaves fried
chicken [ __ ] i go to nashville
i get in that car i head east and
there's a lease fried chicken it's black
and black in there
i go in there get 22 pieces of chicken
for two dollars you know what i'm saying
50 [ __ ] dollars
well how much do you think they're
paying in rent at that place oh they're
paying tremendous rent over there but
look at roscoe's went down the [ __ ]
toilet oh it was terrible no roscoe's in
hollywood is done i hear that roscoe's
on
whatever still has a little bit of
dignity left there's a server the one in
hollywood who listens and he's very nice
but
the uh the food was terrible the food's
terrible i've heard that from various
i've never liked uh roscoe i like
roscoe's though the first time i went to
hang online nobody that was the first
time i tasted a piece of chicken and
maple syrup my dick got hard but i know
it ain't good for you you can't eat
chicken with maple syrup on every
goddamn day nothing good is gonna come
from eating chicken with maple syrup
everything i didn't bring no chicken
with maple syrup the issue with it now
is like it's faster than mcdonald's
they have it ready yeah it's not good we
had it yeah you know i've tried it but i
didn't i never liked it when i first
came out here now next time i go to
atlanta do i go to glasgow no glass
clothes or something [ __ ] up really i
think so last time i went there there
was a line that's why i didn't go down
there yeah go to get somebody to take
you to riverdale georgia that's what
that's right outside atlanta by the
airport and it's a place over there
called annie lords and that [ __ ] is good
let me tell you the best soul food is if
you go to a place and they ain't got no
roaches the food ain't no good
roaches are gonna only hang around while
the food is good so are you like
supposed to see roaches immediately when
you walk in no but uh i haven't seen any
of any lawyers either but the food's so
good you just know some wrong
somewhere this is my take on it you
ready yeah well i see a black style
restaurant with white decor
i tend to stay away from it
the best
food i've ever had right now
raggedy no
this [ __ ] was frying pork chops
on the street with white bread and hot
sauce he must have weighed four and a
quarter
he had a guinea t-shirt on he was
sweating his armpits
and that was pork chops i do eat some
good ass food
oh my god i was 390 and i must hate
eight of those pork chops on white bread
with hot sauce oh my god that was the
best pork chops i ever had in my life i
don't eat pork chops anymore but that's
some good i don't eat pork chops either
but those puerto rican style black style
pork chops
you know that's the best food on the
side of the street no no that's it
that's it all that yes once you see a
blackstone restaurant trying to act like
[ __ ] uh wolfgang puck yeah i don't go
in there that's a waste of your time
you're gonna get a small serving
i
houston got good spots too miss pat you
got so angry when we went for tacos
after the podcast last time because
you're used to east coast tacos uh-huh
and i think we won they and they give
you like the little disc oh my god and
it's like it's like a [ __ ] appetizer
well when you took what did you take the
cactus and what she
i think she got nothing yeah
that little [ __ ] i don't remember
tasting it will go tonight yeah it was
it was like super [ __ ] this no tacos
are good those carne salad tacos
i don't eat pork
i don't eat pork especially if somebody
else cooks it
okay i want to witness it i'm cuban it's
an insult
okay those caught inside the tacos with
that i'm gonna end up eating what you
got here for you gotta get it with the
avocado and the cheese you gotta work on
that keto diet you know what i'm saying
the keto diet avocado that's a good fat
okay they said
they said a lot of [ __ ] is a good fat
until you gain weight right no i
understand you don't listen you're just
gonna anyway let's get back to miss pat
having the [ __ ] kid in the [ __ ]
ambulance that's what people want to
hear not what the [ __ ] is going on in
roscoe's nobody gives a [ __ ] you go to
yelp that's least favorite
my new podcast it's great to see you
first of all you look beautiful i've
heard you know about your success over
the year i read your tweets [ __ ] with
[ __ ]
i'm always going at people i mean thank
y'all so much i mean the podcast family
a lot of this [ __ ] wouldn't happen
without you guys you know back in the
day a lot of comments got day breaks
from johnny carson i gotta say these
podcasts has truly been my [ __ ]
johnny carson what do you think you're
dealing with joy bananas i wouldn't have
dick if it wasn't a podcast
you know why we came out here and told
him the truth i don't give a [ __ ] when i
tell him no more you can't i'm going to
die in [ __ ] ten years there's like i
don't know the whole [ __ ]
brother-in-law yeah because it's true
they're gonna know the whole [ __ ]
story
i just lost um you know my i'm a big
football fan so i went to the falcons
game i went so great for your friend oh
[ __ ] you most of us yeah he got his
boston [ __ ] shirt
jesus christ i got super bowl tickets uh
from lee daniels you know who does
empire because he's the one that's uh
behind my behind the tv show they
developing for me
oh man i tell you it was the worst night
of my life not only did my falcons lose
my um
after we was winning the first two
quarters three quarters
was it three most yeah yeah most of the
night was winning and it was so [ __ ]
up because when we started to lose i
went in the bathroom in here and my
husband texts me and he said my sister
just had a massive heart attack watching
the game and i'm like [ __ ] your sister
i'm about to have a heart attack the
falcon is losing this about to lose the
super bowl then i get a text back that
she died
and it was so [ __ ] up because she died
and
she died the night of the falcon luna
subal so i'm crying but i don't know who
the [ __ ] i'm crying for
and i i told him i told my husband i
said
i tell people i said you might think
it's a bad bad that i lost my
sister-in-law that night but you gotta
look at it like this at least she died
in the third quarter i mean the fourth
quarter she think the falcons won the
super bowl she didn't stay alive to the
whole [ __ ] i'm the [ __ ] that left that
with a heart broke and i almost had a
heart attack but she died just uh she
was cheering for the foul
tom brady gave her a heart attack [ __ ]
yeah tom brady gave everybody a heart
attack
[ __ ] tom brady killed her
so i now hate ronald reagan and i hate
[ __ ] tom brady
running recon kill my dog and tom brady
kept my sister all out damn
so she was cheering and she uh she had a
massive heart attack and died you really
like football though right you really i
[ __ ] love [ __ ] i thought you were
a raven fan for you you ain't thought i
was no [ __ ] raven fan i'm all
the way at least you were ray lewis
ray lewis you don't lost your goddamn
mind i thought you were running with him
slinging this [ __ ] right now
you know what ray lord the black
community is not liking his ass right
now what did he do now he just he that
whole colin kaepernick thing you know
he's saying
i don't know what he's saying but he's
all against colin kaepernick because
he's decided to protest you know for
what he thought was right and this is
america you should be able to protest
when you feel a certain way about a
situation it's not illegal to protest
well that [ __ ] got a job now
who copernicus who copernicus whatever
his name is kaepernick no he ain't got
no he got no [ __ ] job he don't have a
job
we live in a corporate [ __ ] world
before you go into any profession i
suggest you read
that dude i did the longest yard with
that dude had tears coming out of my
eyes what's that white boy that [ __ ]
did the longest yard that was a
linebacker in oklahoma that left early
and then [ __ ] them uh warner brothers
games
came from 21 mil three movies he did the
first one huh yeah he kept the mode yeah
then seattle knew he had bad shoulders
but they got a million dollar insurance
on him
from lloyd to london and they signed
them and they put him up in seattle
and then the nfl hated him they [ __ ]
hated him so he would tuck his shirt out
they would find him his game check
and he kept doing it
i mean the stories of the nfl they don't
[ __ ] around
so copernicus i understand when you're
not kaepernick whatever your [ __ ]
name is
this is america and i stand
i stand what you believe for but there's
different ways of doing it in different
situations i mean you know it's i look
at it like this i look at it like this
[ __ ] camera whatever the [ __ ] his
name is you know that i understand where
he's coming from but you also understand
now that with the world you're well when
do you bring attention to black the
police killing black people when is a
good time to bring attention to that
because it seemed like you know it's you
you know you don't have to worry about
it if it's not in your community and you
know
i drive 35. i'm cuban i'm white and i
drive in l.a worried especially at night
if you don't think i'm worried about
that america you should you should be
able to
you should be able to this was great
about this country this is what's great
about this country you should be able to
protest and and you know get for what
you believe in
there's never a right time you know what
i'm saying it ain't like he went out
there like ray lewis and killed somebody
man ain't never committed a crime all he
did was a silent protest and he did it
two weeks before they even notice it i
mean you know they want to say you
disrespected the national anthem but me
but being black in america i have black
kids you know
it's a it's american this country is
great i love i love this country but
then again you have to think about how
they treat young black men in this
country it's scary being a black mama
today it is [ __ ] scary and i say this
all the time i'd rather fight breast
cancer than be a black painter
of a young black man in this country
because it's something that i worry
about it's like a lot of you don't know
if your child is next
so when do we speak
the last [ __ ] five years some wild
shit's been going on i mean it's crazy
thank god you know sometimes you go i
hate cameras
but now [ __ ] are kind of but
they don't even care they don't even
care the cameras don't even get the
jewelry i mean i don't even talk about
all the other people that have been shot
one thing that really [ __ ] me up joey
is it just google it they shot a 12 year
old boy in a park
in in cleveland ohio for playing with a
toy gun he just out there playing like
any other 12 year old was
if that don't say [ __ ] black people
nothing else will ever will
that's what scares me
we're living in wild times
and you listen and tell me i'm lying i
got a four and a half year old
and if you don't think at one point in
the night when i got up to p
i worry about her future you [ __ ]
count
you know we all worried about i mean we
don't know where we're heading that i
mean all of us together what are we just
[ __ ] did you see like twice in the
past couple months in baltimore
they've their own uh oh my god their own
cameras have caught them planning drugs
on people i'm like come on police
when i sold drugs i wasn't scared of the
police
it was [ __ ] nice people
and it and you cannot clump them all
together because i have friends that
police officer you cannot clump them all
together because there are some good
points
it's some bad apples in every [ __ ]
job and some bad firefighters and bad
teachers for a bad police officer i mean
but
if
it scares me when i get pulled over i'm
scared than a [ __ ] it scares me
this is what scares me
that
they hire these don't they [ __ ] do
evaluations on these police for some
reason these nut bags are passing you've
been there you've been locked up yeah
yeah
now you've been counting or locked up
state i've been stayed okay when you go
to state you're in county for two three
weeks
they talk to you okay then they transfer
you to a [ __ ] evaluation joint
correct yeah they draw blood they check
you out they look in your [ __ ] monkey
they look at your dick they look in your
[ __ ] to make sure you don't have a
set of dice in that [ __ ] got a
dice right then i think i can fit no
doubt in my [ __ ] then they do give
you an aptitude test remember that day
where they ask you what two plus two is
four where's africa
what
what president got shot in the movie
theater
you know they asked you what's out of
school i couldn't ask another one right
and then they get deep in your [ __ ] yeah
and the third it's five days and i
forget what it's called now because
we're talking about it okay
so they do
they do this one test on you where they
talk to you
we don't you don't remember i remember
not vividly yeah you older than me they
just lock my ass up they talk to you a
psych evaluation talks to you then you
take a test
and then you start putting holes and
[ __ ] and then you go back and talk to
that [ __ ]
and then you go
to where your
classification goes you end up going to
where you're going
but that paperwork goes to the feds
and that paperwork is typed in into a
database okay
with your dna with your fingerprints
with your tendencies with what they
think you'll do what what options you
have i mean you know but it's a computer
doing the percentages
of your
what's the word
recidivism recipient whatever the
[ __ ] word is okay they break it down
and that report goes to your prison
counselor how accurate do you think they
are
it changed my life when i heard what it
said on that piece of paper which you're
not supposed to find out your attorney's
supposed to file a motion
and if the state doesn't want to give it
to you i found out because i kept
busting the counselors
and he kept telling me you don't want to
know what's on that paper what did they
say he was crazy they said that uh
at that time i'm 25 i'm 26
and from the age of 16 i hadn't stopped
robbing
some people i knew
drug dealers
and you know when you're not on drugs
all that [ __ ] you start thinking about
it right when you're clean yeah that's
when you start going oh [ __ ]
i don't miss pat a thousand dollars
i'm gonna shoot this [ __ ] no let me go
i got a caller now i'm gonna miss pat
you know what happened i know i know
when i gave you the money you were
cracked up baby but
you know how it is ms bat
so you remember all this [ __ ] you did
and uh
what the [ __ ] are we talking about here
so i kept breaking his balls
so i kept breaking this ball so i'm
feeling bad
that i was robbing people and breaking
into people's houses and drug dealers
and [ __ ]
so i asked him doug tell me what it says
on that he kept telling me you don't
want to know
you don't want to know what it says on
there what the [ __ ] did he say and one
day he broke down he goes all right
[ __ ] i'll tell you what it says
it goes on there that if i had something
you wanted
i can't trust you
if you really wanted it you'd take it
from me
hmm
and i was cracked miss pat i was crying
i went back to that room crying i'm like
i'm just a [ __ ] thief
and i avoided him and one day he came to
me because why you've been avoiding me
he didn't want to hear what you heard
did you
he goes but you didn't hear what i was
saying
he goes i didn't tell you you were a
thief i was telling you that if you want
to do something
you can do it
go do your thing
you got you know what i'm saying like he
encouraged me i took it as i was a thief
so he [ __ ] cracked me miss pat but
all that paperwork goes to the feds
and they tap that and at that time maybe
my [ __ ] slipped it was 88 the computer
system
wasn't untapped but now you go into a
database and as soon as a crime similar
to that happens
your name pops up
yeah you know they have systems now
that's amazing once they got that
fingerprint on you they got you there
for narcotics of a felony
they got your hair they got everything i
don't know i don't that's a good
question how do these bad police
officers get police officer jobs
well okay in 1979 78
the cuban population was growing so much
in miami
that the [ __ ] city council had a
meeting real quick
real quick dog
and so look we ain't gonna get federal
funding unless we start hiring some more
[ __ ] humans
so they went after these kids and they
never did background checks on their
jewelry records
and they hired 20 cops
and this became
[ __ ] huge
this was the 80s when cocaine was
blossoming
they knew information on your dog they
would pull you over
take open up your trunk
take your coke shoot you in the head and
put you in the trunk and leave you on
the side of the road
at the end of the week these guys had a
warehouse full of coke full of coke and
money and they would play cards with a
kilo on the table with a knife in the
kilo and they would just snort for hours
these guys were lieutenants on an
anti-drug unit
so they had all the info
and all four of them if you put river
cops up on the thing not like a video
there's got to be an article about the
miami river cops when they came out they
went to prison like in the 80s
and they came out in late 90s and i was
doing coconut grove then
and people were putting they're gonna
grow yeah people were putting posters up
of these cops
trying to get a petition not to let them
move back into their communities
goddamn that's how [ __ ] crazy these
cops were
they even did a movie about these
[ __ ] so
this [ __ ] starts like this
this is how it starts
you know it starts like this and every
you know
a corrupt cop is somebody who
has three kids
a girlfriend
okay three kids and a girlfriend okay
and guess what and guess what miss pat
you know tell me the truth miss man
you're a street [ __ ] okay yep
you were street [ __ ] okay
you ever watched the show miami vice
oh the first one the real one yeah not
all that's really
yeah yeah lee in miami vice
this is how it went down
i knew lee and you knew miss pat
okay gotcha okay
i walk in to this office right now with
you
you're in for ten percent
miss pat sells me two kilos of coke
in front of miss pat i take a violet
with a chemical i take a little bit of
coke and i shake it to make sure it's
real to make sure it's real and if it
comes up purple i give miss pat the
money and we shake hands let me tell you
something that [ __ ] only happens in the
movie
if miss pat is miss pat miss pat's gonna
want that [ __ ] to open up that
kilo and do three lines of coke
or maybe do a fourth and drink half that
bottle of tequila she wants to know what
this [ __ ] is about before she
moves in on giving him two [ __ ] kilos
okay that only happens in fairy tale
land so these cops become addicted to
drugs yeah a lot of people don't know
that [ __ ] lee so let's say i'm going
after lisa yet lisa [ __ ] big time
coke dealer
i got him with lee
if lisa goes to a club and what do i
tell lisa i don't do blow
you're not going to trust me at least
yeah so i got a small coke
so after you get arrested
they put me in a rehab
i clean up
they withdraw the trial the
witnesses for 45 days taking all the
drugs out of my system they shave me
they change my hair color they put a
suit on me and they make me go in there
with a police uniform on
how's that one for you
holy [ __ ] and there you have it my
friend now miss patton all your days on
this street you ever sell crack to a
[ __ ] you don't see with a pipe
in his mouth
no no okay you could always tell the
police i mean when you you're all noisy
drugs up when you saw enough drugs you
can pretty cause the police no matter
how much they try to blend in somewhere
they don't they don't blend in i
remember seeing one one time in a uh
he had a uh
he he was undercover and he had a
babysitter in the back seat and he had
another guy in the car with him and his
partner jump out and come down the rock
they buy the drugs but he pulled down
too quick so i said either these
[ __ ] gay with his baby seat in
the back uh they're the police and they
was the [ __ ] police
you know how it's a drug dealer you
could ask when you're the police they
supposed to say yes or no
and you like you the police and then i
remember one of the little young guys
like we'll shoot your ass and he left
real quick and i was like this
[ __ ] come back with a whole unit
of [ __ ] i grabbed my kids and went
home everybody got busted to sell me
there was a time there where i had a
dude that was working me that ratted
and he was working me man and i caught
on after the second time what is working
me working me you know
okay so
i know miss pat five years from the
street
miss pat what up i gotta go you know i
give miss pacquiao he was undercover no
he gets busted i'm a coke dude also when
i get busted and they're saying to me
listen what we want is miss pat
miss pat's selling major coke i try to
put him off i like miss pat in my head i
love miss pat
come on go to miss pat
and tell ms pat that you want to buy two
ounces
two ounces
is what they could get you on and give
you time and conviction yeah okay so now
you know i'm joey diaz miss pat he's
been coming over the house for years
buying the gram and he's always five
hours short
now this [ __ ] wants two ounces
of cash
with fresh 50 dollar bills
[ __ ] please
thank you for saying that
that's how they get you sometimes when a
crack can't show up with a lot of money
like what the [ __ ] you getting this
money from you ain't never about over uh
fifty dollars worth of dough you know
what i'm saying you hit the lottery
[ __ ] that's how they used to come at me
so for months you've been buying the
eight ball and asking me for 20 off
because we're friends
and all of a sudden you show up here one
and two ounces then the second time
you know the first time he showed up on
like a half hour
and he was shaking
and then the second time he goes i want
my two ounces but do me a favor i'll
give you the cash let's go outside
so they were up 50 yards with the
[ __ ]
things binoculars and [ __ ] yeah and i
just went outside and i said nah i don't
want to talk my hands too cold
and right there right there when i go
let me call you later
as soon as he [ __ ] left i took all
those [ __ ] scales
all those aluminum falls i got him all
the way out of there i had a job as a
security guard at a hotel
and they gave him
what [ __ ] drug deal i was doing
everything robbing
swinging it was crazy i was a security
you make me sound like a [ __ ] nun oh
my god i was 21 [ __ ] years old man
and i was just watching people check
into the hotel room
waiting to rob them i'd wait till they
go to that hotel room and i'd be right
there when they registered do you want
to use this safe now we got travelers
check bam
when they go skiing you got 10 hours to
go in that room you go in that room and
cook a meal
and come back and then we'll never
[ __ ] know it man
it's [ __ ] crazy they were probably
really excited when they saw you they're
like oh this place has good security
he's i can tell he's like really looking
over us and the security guys are one
rob
there was like eight guys on security so
they never [ __ ] you know that's why i
don't leave my [ __ ] in a hotel me
neither i tell you i don't leave a
person's [ __ ] i don't know what to do
with me and i always put i don't want no
mate in the [ __ ] room either no i
don't wanna made a lot they always throw
away my [ __ ] eyelashes
that's the biggest problem i have with
housekeeping i think the mexican
housekeeping they don't wear eyelashes
so i don't know what the [ __ ] they think
they are but they're reusable and when i
take them off they throw the [ __ ]
away that is the most [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you've ever seen let me tell you my
problem i have made more hotels give me
five dollars for eyelashes i was like
look the [ __ ] to wear my eyelashes i
want my [ __ ] eyelashes back oh
my god listen to me dawg i got a [ __ ]
ear problem
when i was a kid i put a bean in my
right ear
and i didn't tell my mother so they had
to go in my hand they found the bean
so my ears all [ __ ] up did it sprout
kinda
well that's better than having roaches
it was a bean made of wood from a game
called please don't spill the beans
oh it wasn't even a real [ __ ] bee no
but my mother kept putting hot oil in
that [ __ ] and it sprouted
and they took it out of my ear but
anyway today when i fly when i take
showers i got to be careful if water
goes in my hand stays because if i fly
the next day then i go i go deaf
so i gotta go to a doctor they blow it
out and put powder in there and gets
like a fungi in there if i leave the
water in there so i gotta put earplugs
in my every time i take a shower
do you know i put the two earplugs in
the shower and the [ __ ] maid
will throw the earplugs out every
[ __ ] time
i went through two boxes of earplugs in
like eight weeks in the hotel dog
i know they they do this stupid [ __ ]
they don't they don't empty trash can
but they'll throw your [ __ ] eyelashes
away no i stopped letting them in i
couldn't do it i don't let them in no
more either i was like what nobody's
going for the [ __ ] throwing my [ __ ]
away in the [ __ ] room no and i i'm
the type of person like i get i throw my
[ __ ] in the flow so i don't want you
looking at my dirty underwear i don't i
mean i [ __ ] up a hotel room now i
straighten it up at the end
but i will [ __ ] up a hotel i throw
everything on the floor everything at
the suitcase for however many days i'm
there when i when i'm filing leave then
i straighten it up i throw the suitcase
on the couch
i take the three outfits for the three
nights i lay them out nice so yeah i put
the socks right underneath right
and i take the little security bag i put
the suitcase on the side i put away my
sleep apnea machine
you got to sleep i just gave us well
sleep in the machine [ __ ] yeah i got a
sleep apnea machine that [ __ ]
flies right next to me man i couldn't do
that [ __ ] i tried that [ __ ] i mean
it's it's hard how bad is it man
you know what i felt real
it's not sexy at all
so
i mean you can't have that at all huh
you still look healthy what numbers are
you what do you mean what kind of
numbers did you have did you do the
sleep study i yeah i did the sleep study
i don't know the [ __ ] they gave you you
know what they told you tell me the
truth don't i don't know they just said
i had sleep apnea gave him this nice ass
machine okay nice mask nice mask and i
just recently put it on facebook and
gave it to a neighbor
okay so what did they tell you
they told me i stopped a lot of time at
night when i'm breathing well what are
you going to do about it miss pat cause
now you got me all worried i'm going to
be setting up sleeping like a vampire
here
i had a [ __ ] apartment
that i paid 7 20 a month for was rent
control
a one bedroom me and my girlfriend now
who's my wife now
let me tell you something they built the
building in 1922
before the war where they had water for
years
i would go in there i would take a pill
on this bat wrap it up in garbage bag
i put it behind me and i put the shower
on real hot i would sleep for six hours
in that [ __ ] shower the paint would
peel off the walls and [ __ ]
so what are you what so you sleep with a
mask now now i sleep with a mask
and you snow a lot
at that time i was 400 pounds you have
lost something i was doing cocaine
i was smoking cigarettes my diamonds
yeah except smoking reef man
nothing wrong with weed i think it's the
best [ __ ]
thanks for you know
i think it's the best [ __ ] ever so
my numbers have gone down i fell asleep
today well i saw my knees i was icing my
knees the baby was watching uh
something on the computer
and i had something on i think i fell
asleep for 15 minutes how much weight
you lost i have no since the beginning
since i was 418
now i'm walking around between 298 and
303.
oh that's great
yeah so that helped a lot you but i'm
still no [ __ ] olympian i still gotta
stop
did it make your sex life better
damn you took a long deep breath when i
said that one
my sex life got [ __ ] up because of the
cocaine use
because for a long time i was having sex
with cocaine freaks
okay from from
let's be honest here from
from 85 to 91 i was involved with a
woman
and we got married and had a daughter
then we got divorced
and after that i became a comedian in
91.
so from 93
to 2000 when i met my wife
it was
you know and even before that before i
met
kathy
it was 1983-84
where i would just meet you i knew miss
pat
me and you were having some cocktails
you know and all of a sudden i'd give
you a little bump of coke we're talking
let's go back to your house listen to
shaft
you know what i'm saying we go back to
your house
and next you know it's two days later
and we're still eating each other out
you know what the [ __ ] yeah that type of
[ __ ]
like you know
two days later you need to change that
character name i didn't eat nothing for
two days i'm just saying that you didn't
see that coming with us
[ __ ] that drug [ __ ] makes people go
crazy you know i know i gotta need to i
i tell you i'm going through that with
uh i have four kids now four babies at
my house and uh just ran off and left
them so i don't know what she out there
eating but she been going almost a year
and a half almost two years she called
no
she you know what's [ __ ] up she
started a new facebook page and i asked
her to be my friend and she blocked me
that's [ __ ] up
i always uh
when i was a kid there were cartoons and
every cartoon had like a kid running
away from home and he had a broomstick
and around the broomstick was a bad time
like a sleeping like a punching bag
right yeah your handkerchief a hobo yeah
like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
yeah you'd see kids
walking down the street and when i was
like 12 or 13 i thought about it i
wanted to run away and move to french
lake indiana
where larry bird was from
and i'm like oh yeah and i'm like in
those days you had to map it out and
[ __ ]
and i looked at the maps and i'm like oh
hitchhike at that time i had a couple
hundred in the bank
you know but in your mind it's like a
fantasy when you're a kid that one day
you're gonna run away and people gonna
look for you and [ __ ] like that you're
like hang out the balls to run away i
got laundry i got meatloaf twice a week
month
that's [ __ ] up
when a child just runs away
yeah
and they end up on the other side of the
coast
on hollywood boulevard not even
prostitute not even doing nothing bad
they meet another bunch of six kids that
are homeless
and they live in like an old house
that's ready to get knocked down behind
you know we used to live down the corner
here there was a house in the corner the
people sold it
because they wanted to build uh
buildings there like a apartment complex
within a month they had people what do
you call those people squatters squad is
it that they had 12 months what is
squatters
i think it's when you just go in and
live there when you don't have like uh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we i have a
friend
who lived in a different state
and when he went there he didn't have
enough money for rent
he he met someone and they said if you
have a thousand dollars
i can get you a place to live
they met and
when when he got there
they she told them when the people come
back like it was just a house that was
like no one
was at no one had like been to in a
while
she had like a fake deed and she had
keys and they said if they knew if they
ever said if they ever sell it or
something it was like previously
foreclosed if they ever sell it or so
you'll need to get out and he was there
for months
it's [ __ ] up miss pat
so let's pretend
life gets beautiful and you tell your
husband and the children listen we're
like the jacksons we'll leave in gary
indiana you know what i'm saying playing
for indiana
they're from gary gary yeah you say
listen we're enough for this gary [ __ ]
we're moving out there to encino they
bought a house they bought a mansion and
you come out here that house is open the
one that you just left is open yeah you
tell your mom to drop by there once a
week and make sure it's all right or
your dad or your uncle or whatever
and all of a sudden three weeks later
they'll call you and i'll tell you
there's people living in your house and
these [ __ ] got right yeah i was
just gonna say that miss pat they got
more [ __ ] rights and [ __ ] if they're
there for a certain amount of time i
don't know if it's i think it might be
in england i think in england they have
like a lot of rights like like they
actually get to stay in the house [ __ ]
up miss pat they get to stay in the
[ __ ] house
in your house
how do you get them out you gotta like
[ __ ]
i would drag the [ __ ] out of them some
[ __ ]
we put on a monday podcast we didn't
play tony bennett out of respect
sugar daddy
who had loafers in his pants in the
water you can see his ankles
it's that fantasy [ __ ] where somebody's
holding you with their hand on your back
spinning you around like you don't dance
another star
and your weeds just flowing in the air
and you got on clean panties
sounds nice
[Laughter]
don't this sounds sexy you [ __ ]
you trying to catch an ass td ain't you
you like your girl panties dirty is it a
big thing that you think you know
super dirty just a little dirty look let
me ask you is it a big thing that women
underwear should match
that's what who cares like the bra in
the in the panties for years i've been
wearing holy underwear and i would wear
my bra to the [ __ ] stream pop out of
it
i'm not a fan of excuse me i'm not a fan
of victoria's secret oh i can't [ __ ]
fit victoria's secret i don't know about
your wife i'm a fan of little [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i'm a fan of a woman
who just makes a pair of underwear look
good
can't understand me so how do you make a
pair of underwear well see i don't have
a flat stomach so we gotta come over my
stomach it don't matter you know okay
you know what i like almost better than
thongs is boy shorts like because i
can't [ __ ] do the boy shorts like who
are my [ __ ] no no no no no and i'll
tell you what
in some instances and i believe in god
in some instances
in some instances i believe in the song
but i also believe there's some
[ __ ] that should know where we
thought
i i totally agree okay if you i can't
wear them i want a woman to walk in my
room with a of panties on
that i don't give a [ __ ] if they got a
hole in them
she makes those things look banging if
the bra is different that's good because
now you can rip it and i got an excuse
they didn't match anyway
even if it's a 40-hour bra you can rip
the bra
you know what i'm saying i wish my
brother costs four you take now when you
take those underwear off let's pretend
you what do you see
like if now i don't look in the old days
and the cocaine days i wouldn't look
till later what do you mean you don't
look i wanted to play [ __ ] let me
sniff the monkey and guess the yoda you
know what i'm saying
holy [ __ ] i would that's how i throw
them off
that's how i get the monkey and guess
the older i'm like like
give me an order that you smell
piss
i was a freak listen to me i'd be a
freak jack listen to me
so let's pretend i met you
let's pretend did you stop
let me tell you what a nasty cuban freak
out was so let's pretend we hooked up in
ten had a couple cocktails
at 11 30 12 you said to me joe you want
to come back to my place we're all
[ __ ] up we know what time it is we go
back to your place we put on the eisley
brothers we dance a little bit we make
believe
black music
you're thinking
i'm gonna let this brother out here
chill for a little while i'm gonna go
inside and freshen up a little bit
take a shower i mean i don't know what
time it is i'm gonna go wash it good
but a freak like me i don't want to i'll
never give you that opportunity
as soon as you start telling me baby i
gotta go
i want that monkey [ __ ] real you know
i want it to be real what's that song to
be real got to be real got to be here
to get the wrong monkey
in the cage i want that muffler i want
it all then after what whatever
that's nasty joy no you got to take a
chance that's part of love said you ever
had something that you had to get off of
why are you thinking one time
one time
one time
two weeks after my mother died
a girl that i was kind of in love with
kind of had a crush on she was a year
younger than me
very very cute very blue eyes
you know we were young
sucking teddy finger that i kind of ate
her
but this all [ __ ] happened on the street
so my mother dies and she calls me one
night
and she just puts it out there listen i
know you're probably feeling bad
what if i came over and you a little
something so
like this is 1979.
and the thing was on that night the one
with steve mcqueen
the one the blob the blob the block
oh i do remember dawg i walked all the
way over to a house gotta walked all the
way back to my house it was [ __ ]
freezing we go upstairs we swap spit the
lady who took care of me after my mother
died she was sleeping in my mother's
room i took her into my bedroom we
swapped some spread i took her shirt off
she had great breast
i took a pants off i'd taken panties off
it was 1979 so kotex
were like this [ __ ] thick and that
[ __ ] it was like brief this
pattern just opened up and i almost had
a heart attack
she put that thing back on i made her
walk home by herself i ain't got time
over here offering me a piece of ass and
also that shit's bloody [ __ ] my mother
just died i just found my mother on the
floor and you're gonna show up over here
with a bloody snatch
what the [ __ ] is wrong with americans
you know what i'm saying
that is one that you had to get up for
thank god for that one you believe
that's the only time every chance i've
taken
it's the older i expected the owner i
wanted
because that's the turn to mom when they
say to you you know baby i want to
freshen up a little bit i ran like three
miles that's when i'm looking in the eye
and i go listen that's how i want to eat
it oh god joey
i want to eat that you don't want to eat
no track [ __ ] yes i do
she was so shocked they made her
pronounce your name like the end it
would say something
especially if it's got hair it's crazy
hair oh my god if it's got a little hair
on it
and you go to yoga oh good job can i
catch you right before you go in that
shower
oh my god i spread it out oh joey you
[ __ ] take that little garlic smell
out of that [ __ ] garlic what
what did you do with a garlic smell it
smells like garlic but once you get deep
oh it smells like ammunition
it probably is ammunition the [ __ ] is
you talking about
that's why you coughing like that that's
that 79 vagina in your throat i was like
it smells like gun powder like that it
gets in deep
deep in there
and then you you make sure you won't
need no robot no that's how i like it i
like yoga person
gunpowder and while you're licking the
[ __ ] you're sniffing the hair patch
and it's like
like it just smells [ __ ] tremendous
right above that little monkey oh joey
no
right about that clint about an inch and
a half with that little sweater i hope
your wife don't listen to this no my
wife don't do i don't do this to my wife
this is what i was doing i'm just saying
i don't want her to know what you did in
79. i don't give a [ __ ] she knows
she got me tested twice
i don't blame her
you eating gym [ __ ] you should be
tested twice oh my god
i got tested twice and then one time
before we got married it came up i had
syphilis and my wife was like what the
[ __ ] my wife was pregnant
and it came up that sheep didn't have
syphilis
so we're like what you got the usher
dick and then we went back
and they retested me
and it was something that i was eating a
pill gave me a reaction there was no
[ __ ] syphilis
let me ask you something
i never ever ever when i heard this the
first time
i was working at fox sports i had just
moved here
it was 1997
and at fox sports there were three
sisters like yourself from atlanta
the south and they all worked in
different divisions of fox but when they
got together the black came out
and they would talk
the black gossip of the community
and
they started talking about murphy being
gay
will smith is gay and
you know i don't believe in any other
freaking although the bro these people
had paperwork you know those type of
sisters they were in
the business they were going to these
parties they were in the know
when they've heard when they first told
me about eddie murphy that there was
somebody else they told me about
that i almost [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants
and then one night i was at the store
and eddie murphy was there with paul
mooney arsenio hall
and
the singer
the black singer from
the
whitney houston's husband's band bobby
brown what's the other singer with that
new edition
oh johnny hill he was a johnny gill
and uh
and richard pryor's manager was up there
drinking
with a [ __ ] he used to get [ __ ] up
up there i forget what his name is
and he we i was standing there with a
couple other comments and he looked at
me because cuba
you want to see me rattle these
[ __ ] watch this he walked up to
him and he goes hey
so what are you [ __ ] going to
do the queen's economy tour
and they just [ __ ] split dog
at this time when i had heard all this
[ __ ]
it was
it was mind-boggling
and then i asked eddie griffin
nothing griffin would tell me different
stories of [ __ ] i didn't know about but
what the [ __ ]
is going on with us i don't want the
white version how much i want the black
let's hold on let's first talk about it
we enjoy the guy that pees about that
guy
break down the black side of this oh my
goodness
i don't i mean all i know is rkl is
supposed to be keeping some girls in
this house and it's supposed to have a
coat but you know supposed to not let
them go i don't know they all went on
youtube and say they was fine yeah but
that's the first thing i'm gonna have
you do in a cult
you have to admit that there's no wrong
let's hold on let's trace it all the way
back i thought he had like a
[ __ ] married to leah 14 yes
okay
then tapes resurfaced
i've never seen the tape have you seen
the tape i don't even want to see him he
doesn't see marrying the wheel i'm
pissing him off i'm pissing on him
pissing on the girl the underage girl so
he's been in trouble several times he's
bought himself out yeah he's not tons of
money he just bought rent i do i mean i
kind of think something is wrong with
our killer you know it's like nobody's
gonna keep crying crying the same thing
about a particular person
you know it's like it's almost like when
bill cosby got in trouble with all those
women you know at first as a comic and
you know bill cosby's allegedly you know
five two three we know oh go [ __ ]
yourself from the 70s why would he cheat
on his wife
yeah then it's 50 you're like wait
a minute well not even at 50 at 10 you
was like come on y'all it's just too
many people with the same story
i think i lost it as five and i was like
it's just too many people saying the
same [ __ ]
about this person
so you know they're going to retract
them
are they
i mean i want to believe i want to
believe it's not true but i mean when so
many people come out and say the same
thing same thing with r kelly everybody
saying the same thing you know you for
some reason he like his monkey young
and what about usher
oh she's just supposed to be going
around giving [ __ ] hot dicks
he's supposed to have a syphilis
you know i guess that's why he made this
song let it burn
and the new girl today came out she was
a plus-sized girl and the internet did
her no justice
no jessie somebody i heard somebody say
she sure she slept with the right usher
the ush the usher the singer or the
usher from the concert understand that
what did you think was gonna happen when
she went like
why didn't you just ha sue i'm sure how
did you put on a cup well the first girl
got a million dollars so now everybody
wants a million dollars but you don't
need to do a press conference but my
thing is is that evidently he was flared
up when he [ __ ] that girl you can't
say uh she gay you you don't have a
herpes so you wasn't in dangers if you
wasn't flared up
and you know i said it earlier you want
you know it's like when you lay down
with somebody you you um you don't
protect yourself and you say well this
person didn't tell me they had it well
you didn't tell him what the [ __ ] you
had
i mean if you're going to do one night
stands i i truly believe both sides
should say what you got
yeah so you got to ask the question hey
is your dick on regular or is it
irregular look at me
i'm not a good looking guy when i saw a
piece of [ __ ] it came as it came if it
had [ __ ] some type of well you eating
gym [ __ ] that's different no gym [ __ ]
i would meet girls and bar you know you
do comedy you're an indianapolis you're
in indianapolis i'm in uh
bozeman montana
and i i got the weekend there friday and
saturday it's part of a one night a week
you start on tuesday and end up in
bozeman
the first show the door girl's cute we
talk a little bit
the second show we talk a little more
uh she sees me i go outside and smoke
pop when i come back she goes you should
have asked
you know now you have an idea what's
going on you didn't protect yourself now
saturday night you don't [ __ ] know
saturday night you come back and now
she's talking to you about weed
and she says yes she loves doing blow
and you go show the why can you get
something she goes yeah
i have a friend that get you an eight
ball for 200 bucks you tell him to be
here at 12 after the second show
boom you get it
you give her two bumps she comes out she
tells you about her boyfriend who's in
the navy
and she misses him and she loves him so
much and when he comes back he's going
to propose to her and [ __ ] and you start
talking to her a little more and
actually you know she asked you for two
more bumps and you talked to her about
[ __ ] uh this or that
and she just told you
that she had a boyfriend and shit's on
the back of your mind
you're doing coke but hopefully another
she's good looking so maybe another
freak will come over
and start talking to me but this one
here wants to talk to me so eventually
it's called it too
and now this
this girl's like what are you gonna do
are you gonna go home and finish that
package
and i'm like no i'm gonna go home and
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna go home and
finish that package and they'll ask you
do you want company
yeah for one company next thing you know
you stop at a liquor store and get a
[ __ ] case of beer a carton of
cigarettes and you go to the hotel room
you start snorting at two
by seven o'clock somebody's gonna be
naked
you eat each other out you're 69. you
eat everybody oh god because you got to
lick that monkey i'm a savage
you're 69. you suck that that's somebody
69.
you got almighty when i was this when i
was young this is when i was young
i was verbal i haven't heard of this
pick women up and [ __ ]
you you got to stop eating everybody you
meet joey yeah that's dangerous listen i
come in a minute so i got to make a good
impression
at that time i was coming real quick
especially if i just met you i was
excited just to take my dick out
i'd blow up as soon as my dick touched
your [ __ ]
it was terrible when i was a kid
so i didn't i what my plan was i'm
surprised you don't have a lot of so
this is what my plan was when i was once
i got divorced was when i realized i had
a problem with ejaculation problems
like something was [ __ ] with my head
what was you who was you
when i first when i first moved out from
colorado i could put some dick onto you
in 85 i'm in a store this one night and
i would get some ejection
and
and then i met a man a neighbor and all
she wanted she was 22 in college and i
don't want to have sex but i'll give you
blow jobs what the [ __ ] is that so i
would go to a house at night and after
like an hour of bad tv
she tucked my pipe that was it
then i met my future wife
and we were both into coke and once we
moved to aspen
those were [ __ ] six hour sessions
and you know once i come you got to
start sucking again
oh god and then i would start eating
your ass until my you know so in those
days
i knew i would come quick so my plan
would be to seduce you
lay you down eat your monkey while i was
eating your monkey the excitement would
make me dizzy and [ __ ] and i was what
yeah because i got anxiety attacks
so i'm not a handsome dude so i know if
i got a chick laid down looking up and
her legs around she's not screaming and
she's not screaming and there's no mace
in the hand
i'm excited you know what i'm saying
so i'm meeting that little monkey
next thing you know miss pat i wag
myself out oh i come real quick
and then
i get it like semi-hard she's hot as
[ __ ] i switch over i put my stominki in
her mouth and i just finger-bang her she
blows her little monkey she brings my
dick back to life now i go back in there
like a superhero because i'm refueled i
crack the nut the anxiety's gone
and then i'm king khan
and it's all over but to shout they just
tap and not stop stop jesus christ
let's do some more coke [ __ ] it put a
coke rock in your [ __ ] let me look at
that [ __ ] oh
i'm like oh yeah miss pat come on dog we
were the real deal in the [ __ ] 80s i
wasn't doing all that [ __ ] joy
goddamn i was with one guy he was
married but damn you made my story sound
okay
and then i was married i was very good i
went to prison i was very good i got
married
and then once i started calmly
i always had a certain respect for women
thank you for that until i started
coming i saw the other side of women
damn i saw
what women are capable of doing
and how quick they could do it
it's it's just
women are just as vulnerable as men are
and men are just as vulnerable as women
are
you know when you go on those triple
runs have you ever heard of triple rush
triple runs are when you first start in
comedy and let's say you live in denver
after about six months you kind of got
10 minutes
you do a little impr what's that called
improvised where are you from crowd work
yeah you found triple one you send a
mature you send them a check you send
them a tape and he puts you with a
headline and he takes you to montana
wyoming
idaho
washington state oregon and you would go
for six or seven weeks
and you will learn how to become a
comedian miss pat you know
some places you get there they give you
a note don't curse they're mormons
you got to clean up your act or not they
throw rocks to hear some [ __ ]
what do you think happens when you go
from these towns to towns
you know triple runs are not in portland
oregon
they're
180 miles up in the mountains
that people come down into the city once
a month
to get groceries
so let's pretend you weren't extra on
friends
that night on the radio they said this
guy was seen on friends
every woman and husband go down to these
towns those trouble runs were a
tremendous scam would it be like going
to like big bear
or something like that yes it's going to
places where
there's no entertainment at night so he
would pick five of those in a row monday
he would do wednesday thursday friday
saturday and then either saturday or
sunday or the hotel
and it would sell out they didn't care
who you were yeah i've been in places
like that they don't care who you are
they just go down there and laugh
at those places i learn more about women
that's when i learned the dark side of
women that damn yeah
they would get you to the hotel and get
that one hotel what did it get you into
the car wait till you fall asleep
what the hell are you talking
what
about
are you talking about well whoever holds
rob
she goes up
the empty goes up
he does 15 minutes
i go up there i do 35 minutes and 22.
i look like johnny hero i get off the
stage
where's the first place i go i go to the
bar i get a drink i pick up my [ __ ]
eight ball
and i lurk by the bathroom
how's how do you manage to find drugs in
every place you call because you talk
about it on stage
oh wow so you'll go jesus christ one
night i was doing an eight ball with
these people people clap
those people that clap afterwards
they'll come up to you and go dog you
want to do a blast yeah let me do it can
you get more yeah my buddy's got some
cylinder graham and coke it's that fast
oh wow
hold on wait [ __ ] uh
wesley snipes is flying over
he's saving the plane and [ __ ] like that
so august 22nd what happens
i was 22nd my book dropped um
kyle rabbit it's a memoir it's on it's
online my website misspentcomedy.com
august 25th through the 26th i'm doing a
book signing in indianapolis at morty's
comedy joint so we're gonna do four
shows and four book signings
so
uh people can come out and do a meet and
greet and get their books signed and
watch the show
how long was the process of the book
two years
it takes a long year from the time yes a
lot of thought and like you said
you get to you get the certain chapters
that
you write it out and then you read it
and you go you know what
i got to do something else
and you
you have to go for a ride
yeah i mean
the lady who wrote it with me which is
her name is janine amber
um oh so much back and forth there was
so many tears it was just it was we just
you know like she would write something
and i was like that's not my voice then
she'll go fix it so it was it was
interviewing a lot of people
you know like from my past and
she's from she's a she's black but she's
from canada and she was scared to uh
some people were scared to talk to her
because she spoke correct correct
english they like who is this white
[ __ ] and i'm like she's not white she's
black
so
it was just you know digging up old
stuff it was it was a lot it was a lot
of work it's a lot of work to write in a
book well you know man you know being an
author
and you know honestly she sat there and
she put this story together which i
thought she did a wonderful job
and you know it's getting good reviews
and made memoir of the month for amazon
but it was some hard [ __ ] work it was
let me tell you i've done i thought i've
done hard [ __ ] in my life but this book
this book is a it put me to it miss pat
i'm working on four years on this
[ __ ] book
because the the chapters i gotta write
i gotta go to such a [ __ ] dark place
yes that i thought like because there's
times i find myself there i'll eat a
couple of these [ __ ] stars and i'm
driving home and that song will come on
call me when you and i think of summer
82
when i was 18 years old
no parents
lived in my friend's basement
no car no bank account
i lived hand to mouth his mother charged
me 50 a week to live there
all my responsibilities i took out
garbage
and i [ __ ] did laundry had to do my
own laundry and fold it that was it man
everything else that came into my pocket
miss bad i had to do whatever i [ __ ]
had to do and you know what
you try to work
you're trying to work for a while you go
what the [ __ ] is this
i could sell an 8-ball make this in
[ __ ] 10 minutes i got to be here
mopping the floor for eight hours and
[ __ ] yeah i mean that was like
with me it was just that i was so young
so it was so hard to get a job
because i was so [ __ ] young
but you know
i overcame a lot of [ __ ] and you know
writing this book writing this book tell
stories that i never really told like it
it tells stories about situation like
when i got when i read the book you i
literally cried some like chapter five
i
i never told anybody about chapter five
when my husband read it he was [ __ ]
shocked
so it's you know it's just me telling
stories that i i was never able to tell
openly so i just i just open up and say
i'm gonna tell you as much as i can
remember
how do you feel about it now that you're
fine i like it i really do i do it's you
know when when we first finished it last
year and the editor was like no
you got to start over i was a little
upset but i tell you it was the right
decision and it made the book a better
book
so it actually reads like a movie it's
it's a really good book it's amazing
what you think like i want to be a part
of the writing
in my world i want to write it i want to
write it
send it to the editor let him fix it put
it together
my agent gordon and then we'll put the
presentation package together let him
put all the p's and cues i'm just trying
the best i can but it's taken me
i started writing a blog on myspace
every monday
that's how i got myself back into
writing a blog about my life in order
every monday about something that
happened
in high school i went to a party and a
fight broke out and i stepped on a piece
of [ __ ] glass something's going on
something's on [ __ ] fire dog
yeah
so you know
i'm just glad it's finished that's the
big
finally i feel like i accomplished
something you know because you have so
many uh fires going at one time
but nothing really cooking so one thing
i can say about the book is finally done
that's what i'm happy about you know we
i sold i sold a pilot to fox last year
along with lee daniel and um
ron howard company imagine
and you know that's just kind of up in
the air we're still working on it and
and it's
finishing this book just put i was able
to complete something so i'm just glad
it's completed
it's crazy how
how many people
and i'm not
uh
i don't even know the word
while i lived here
people moved to this town
got hooked up with
conan o'brien yeah you know and they got
great director and they got somebody
great to write the pilot
and
take the pilot no nothing you know
it's such a hard collaboration
you went into it going i'm going into
this [ __ ] with lee daniels the
[ __ ] black dude of the month
all right no forgot empire i watched
empire for three seasons then it went
somewhere else now i was done
they tried to go to dynasty the first
two seasons i love everybody i love the
gay son
i love you know you know what let me
tell you why i fell in love i watched a
pile of that [ __ ] and there was
a dude who used to write on that staff
and even less
and he goes make sure you watch the
pilot the pilot
[ __ ] my [ __ ]
up jack that's a good [ __ ] job you
know when
when he rules wednesday night when he
put
the little gay kid
was about five
and homie was in the living room and
against the capital
and the two other kids were babies and
that little kid came in the gay one
he walked in the room with a dress on
and women's heels like his sister's
shoes
and what's his name howard what's it
what's uh tara's house time and time was
reading like a paper with gold teeth and
[ __ ]
and he looked up and he saw this kid
and he [ __ ] slammed down the paper
he picked this [ __ ] kid up
took him down the stairs opened up a
metal garbage can
and put him in the garbage can head
first
i remember that scene and i was like god
damn right there
because i remember when i came from my
my buddy was was black
and their family was not [ __ ] gay
friendly
well black the black community is just
the black community
has came around in the last five to ten
years with i think they you know well i
think the world is beginning to say you
know do what makes you happy absolutely
and that's what it's all about you know
stop living for other people if you you
know do what makes you [ __ ] happy
that's what i had to learn i mean for
years i've tried to make other people
love me and other people you know
be put other people before me and i
learned in the end
i got to [ __ ] love myself when i love
myself and respect myself everybody else
will begin to care and respect me
you know what i'm in the whole school
like the man said
if you want respect you got to give
respect yeah treat me with respect that
you want
i stay away from people i'm no no i'm
the same way i'm old man
yeah i'm getting ole miss pat that
little four and a half year old wears me
out
now i feel yeah i got four of them at
the house and you know
that's this was
i just i just hope people realize you
know after reading the book you know
be you do what makes you happy because
that's what i ended up doing numbers pat
what years is this book covered
uh it just go from childhood from
growing up in the bootleg house
to
prop to my marriage
it doesn't talk about uh the comedian
much miss pat
you know it tells you how i kind of got
started but i'm to 93
well
yeah when did you start counting miss
matt i started comedy
i'm 15 years in
so by night 2000 were you a storytime
from the beginning no
i didn't i didn't you were slipping for
a long time like i did yeah i didn't i
didn't know i told stories like i
i really didn't think my past was that's
funny until you know i would constantly
tell people
and people say you got unique stories
won't you put them on stage and then you
know it's all about then you got to
figure out how to put them on stage
so you know when i moved to indianapolis
in 2006 is when i really realized i was
a storyteller
it took me
eight years to tell a story on stage
and once the first time you do it
it blows
yeah [ __ ] mind
and it means that like i was in the
belly room
at that time the belly room meant [ __ ]
to me do you understand me miss pat i
didn't move to atlanta to do spots in
the belly room lee i was getting room
sets in the original room
and one night i went into the belly room
somebody goes bro you gotta do this show
it sold out please go upstairs just we
have nobody else
and i kind of want to say with attitude
and [ __ ]
miss pat i ate a bag of dicks
the first joke died
second joke died third joke died
and i said [ __ ] you [ __ ] until
this day i can't remember what story i
told you it was this i mean you probably
you've been doing comedy so long now
does it bothers you when a joke don't
hit no
me neither i don't give a [ __ ] because i
tell young comics i said you know when
you're working i mean it's like baking a
cake it's like baking a cake and that
[ __ ] falling in the middle okay you
didn't add the right ingredients go back
and try again
and people ask me how time you're like
does it bother you i he'll come and say
well oh when i have a good set i have a
good week when i have a bad [ __ ] i have
a bad week i don't give a [ __ ] is it
when i'm not when you didn't pay to see
me and i'm literally up there at an open
mic i am creating i'm working so i don't
give a [ __ ] about how you feel about a
joke okay it didn't work then i go home
and i took you to rework it and come
back
but i see a lot of comics they get
really depressed that open mic and i'm
like [ __ ] you had to open mike what you
gonna do when you was [ __ ] in front
of a thousand people one day and you
bombed
when i was on the road mr joe rogan mr
joe rogan used to pay me good money
the show don't look like you pay good
joe paid me great money and he knew my
money was going half of it was going to
drugs he still loved me
he still knew i was funny
but he also knew i was a hammer nagger
i was a 50 comic
i would go up there to all this thought
if it ran miss pat
you got problems [ __ ]
you got to follow joey after that set
that's one of those cocaine from the
night before fuel set and he knows he's
picking up another rock and an hour type
set
he just wants to get this set over with
so he's trying i would [ __ ] kill
rooms and joe would love it but there
were also sats guys that i would go up
there and eat a bag of dicks
why did i did i get a notebook no i went
to dinner with miss pat and i got high
with miss pat's husband
and then i went to indianapolis and did
do not drugs but smoke pot you know what
i'm saying uh-huh now people pay to come
see us in this pack yes so now guess
what i do on friday before the show what
nothing i don't want to see nobody i
want to talk to you i don't what do you
want to talk about
i got two shows they're paying 25 hours
to come to see me yeah okay i don't want
you in your room going me me me me me
that's [ __ ] i want you in your room
with your feet up
at about five o'clock you go down to the
gym you got on the bicycle
you do 20 minutes you do a couple
jumping jacks you get everything nice
and sweaty you go upstairs you order a
little room service because if you go to
the bar you gotta sit there for an hour
you ain't got now
before the room service comes up you
pray he says 70 for 45 minutes you're
sweaty you take your notebook out
and you go over your notes
and you and i'm not telling you to write
i didn't say nothing about right
i just said to go through that notebook
because going through that notebook
will raise your percentages right then
you took a shower your mind was calm
and you were set on the thing
i love the comic that walks in miss
patton says
man i want biggie as my warm-up song
that dude already lost he's thinking
about his song yeah that's why i give
[ __ ] what you play you play with saying
that's why i don't that's why i don't
bring t-shirts on the road
i don't want to be worried about 62
t-shirts
and size double axe you know what i'm
worried about my [ __ ] stand up
i want these people to come see me next
time
so when you're a feature act you act a
certain way and when you're a headliner
you gotta act a certain way
and next thing you know good things
happen for you man and i didn't make
this up i watched bernie mac
i watch you know the great ones i love
richard pryor
you go out there and focus on what the
[ __ ] you're doing years ago i used to go
[ __ ] joe rogan and his myspace [ __ ]
joe was on my space i'm snorting blow
going do you think richard pryor would
go home and get on my space
do you
do you think richard pryor would go home
with his prime and get on my space [ __ ]
you my space [ __ ] one day we
did irvine
and that [ __ ] room was sold out
on fourth of july weekend with no radio
and i said this [ __ ] or
something this was
ten years before the podcast
oh wow he was already on to that [ __ ] he
was already getting the people through
the internet
so it's been an education
listen you and i are both
uh prime examples that if you open your
heart on these podcasts
yeah great things can happen this all
started with us telling people about our
lives how great is this
it sure was i mean i i can't thank the
podcast family enough every one of y'all
you joey mark
ari bert
tom segura and his wife
and so many more i can't [ __ ] name
like the first time you came in here you
got a [ __ ] up eyebrows you sure had
[Music]
your nails weren't done and [ __ ]
you had a [ __ ]
you had a fugazi diamond on this [ __ ]
you had one of those cuban zirconiums on
look at this
you went to a steam room they rubbed you
down
they plucked your eyebrows they gave you
a little shampoo and [ __ ] they gave you
that korean rug
that's how good you look they took that
old what's [ __ ] shirt with the hole
in it y'all know you threw it away it's
over i'm not gonna bring it up this [ __ ]
you brought it up from north carolina in
1982.
i like how he said that's the easy way
to say [ __ ] was ugly no i did not i
did not say about ugly i just said that
you know
there was no dollars coming in you know
now you're looking good
god bless you she just turned my hand
and her hands are so soft oh my god no
no no she goes to like a dog oh my god
she goes to the
nail salon every day you shea butter
like other black people do oh [ __ ] you
talking about them
that's good shape by this he used to get
butt
you used to get shaped by the two for
one
with afro that's premium right now you
get the real shape butter butter
butter the [ __ ] you rub on your feet and
your feet don't crack you know oh i have
been blessed i i can't lie about that i
i gotta be honest i've been blessed i
mean some good things have really came
my way you know the book the whole ly
daniel thing would uh imagine i mean
sometime i wake up and i was like what
the [ __ ] did i do to deserve this you
know i get to talk to a powerhouse you
know almost any time i want like lee
daniel and always giving me an advice
great great dude great dude to know i
mean been nothing but nice you know
and how did you get in contact with him
well um
well i did i saw well we i first had a
deal with new regency uh
and my contract ended so we we left and
literally uh imagined called a couple
days later and wanted me to meet lee so
i went out to chicago and i was like oh
they shoot they shoot empire in chicago
so i was like i don't really nobody you
know i'm scared he's gonna be really
famous
acting and you know i'm saying well what
do i say to this big time guy you don't
wanna oscar need monster ball precious
you know you don't really know how
people gonna act ended up being the
[ __ ] realest person i ever made in my
life i mean just just like me and you i
mean you know how you meet somebody he's
like i want to choose my words right you
know
immediately made me feel like
you know i was just as equal as him you
know you can meet some people that make
you feel like ah i'm up here yeah
talking down to you not one time i ever
felt like that you know not one time
a great dude and you know he took me in
with his team to fox and we sold the put
pilot which was you know now we we gotta
we just we had to switch writers
uh
so we got a new writer and we go on and
pitch it again and hopefully it'll get
up and going but
i can't say anything about bad about
imagining lee daniel uh any of those
guys number one brian grazer you have
been blessed dearly because yes lee
daniels has a successful [ __ ]
tremendous numbers
show on two two stars
so that means he's got three more four
more shows left him yes okay and yours
is one on that list
apparently the stars may not fall now
but he regroups and take that
[ __ ] netflix of cbs
you know everybody's buying shows right
now yes so you know you're in good
[ __ ] hands so you
really got to get up in the morning and
say jesus [ __ ] i do i thank god every
day you know i just everything i mean
then
not only that what people don't know
it's the behind the scenes stuff that he
studied do to help my career you know he
read my book he gave me a blurb he you
know
he didn't have to do that
i got an article coming out in the
washington post and the 20th on the 20th
you know
he just he he does so much other stuff
like if i ask you know and it's just for
my career
is lee can you do this for me sure what
do i need to do you know that's the
scary thing the biggest thing is i'm
scared to ask
but whenever i do ask
you know it's always yes and i mean i'm
a person where you know i've been
through so much in my life i like to
earn what i get in this world i don't
want to be handed any [ __ ] thing
and
you know i i don't i haven't give we
haven't produced a show where
everybody's getting paid yet so i really
don't like asking i feel i don't want
nobody to ever think i'm just there for
them to give me anything i want to work
for whatever i get so that's the scary
part about this business too you know
they'll fly you out there put you up and
invest in you and [ __ ] don't work out i
feel like i've taken advantage of
somebody
so my whole thing is i just i want i
always i just like to work for what i
get
and that's what i constantly tell all of
them i just i want this show to be
successful so you know we all can make
some money from it so i don't feel like
i'm some [ __ ] freeloader the first
two three four
five six months in the business
did you ever think you'd be in this
position [ __ ] no no no i tell leonard i
had five years
of doing comedy did you think you'd be
in this position with the hottest
three producers in hollywood and [ __ ]
opie you're in business with [ __ ]
imagine
can you [ __ ] imagine like
when you're at doing that one night and
people are talking about going to
montreal and you're sitting there like
an animal you don't even have a manager
and this all changed because
you went on a few podcasts and opened
your heart and [ __ ] people were blown
the [ __ ] away yeah they had never heard
and then the same thing happened with me
i told [ __ ] that i would never tell
anybody i i thought this happened in
everybody's life yes yes most definitely
i mean again no i didn't think 10 years
10 years ago
i mean in 2006 when i moved from atlanta
to indianapolis no i did not think that
this is where i would be at in 2017.
no
i mean my whole thing is always just
saying i just want to get into clubs i
just want to be a feature then you get
to feature everyone now if i could just
make a thousand dollars a week that's 5
000 a month i can help my husband pay
the bill or i have enough money to get
my layaways out on time you know that's
always been my biggest focus don't
[ __ ] let your little way go back so
uh i just wanted to make up enough money
so i can be independent you know all of
this other stuff with a book and you
know a book shocked the [ __ ] out of me
because i was like you [ __ ] right
y'all gonna buy this [ __ ]
it was shocking you know because i
always wanted to tell my story but i
can't write a [ __ ] book i knew i
couldn't write it so when it came along
i'm first of all let me say i'm the type
of person where i grew up don't believe
the half of the [ __ ] you hear
don't believe half of the [ __ ] you see
and none of the [ __ ] you hear
so i needed to be 100 before i [ __ ]
believe in it
and when the lady came along and said
she could write the book or whatever
we'll see and when it really happened it
i was like well damn
would you do it again would you write
another book would i write another book
it was hard
my husband said i got another book in me
i don't know i have two more in you
number one
you have uh
you have one story
now like but you have to also write it
and look at yourself and go you know
what i'm gonna write this about me
but i'm writing this for
viveka fox
because
i'd rather
sell this
and then become an academy award one and
guess who wrote it and now guess how
much they give me for my next one eight
million and on that one i can write a
story about my [ __ ] they already wrote
the check
that's what happens to people in
hollywood
your second one is about
your kids
just flip it
that's an oprah movie
that goes right to oprah you tell lee
hold on one second we already got this
thing cooking i gotta go talk to oprah
about this one
this is about a 15 year old girl who has
a relationship with a married man and
it's two children
and it's you but it really isn't you
when it ends
maybe with what you how you want it to
end
and then there's the other side
of a single mom that's 17 slinging
[ __ ] on the corner
you have three or four books in you
that's my husband i always say he's like
you got another one but who knows yes
you just have to get a notebook
get a book the art of writing get all
that book read them but the most
consistent thing is to say to yourself
you know what i'm going to write 10
words a day
that's it 10 [ __ ] words a day a
[ __ ] child can write 10 words a day
and next thing you know you start
getting into it and get into it more and
getting into it more than a year and a
half from now you got yourself a little
book baby girl
and now your advances a little higher
you have a bigger follower from stand up
how many [ __ ] go
i don't we don't have time believe we
sit here how many comedians have made
millions from book that first chelsea
handler book made like 12 million you
know and then she was taken on the road
and stadiums
and banging you out for 30
to sign the [ __ ]
you know you have to look that's
commerce this is what this business is
about and this is what you're good at
you have 10 stories in your [ __ ] soul
well we'll see you know i i don't know
right now i just finished one so
hopefully yeah it's going to do well
august 22nd august 22nd is on pre-sale
now
please go out and order it
you know what's crazy joy my husband
read it and i was i you know my husband
is a big critic you know a lot of time i
say he's not a miss pet family he's
really on the cover miss pat fan
and he was like this is a [ __ ] movie
this is a good book yes and he didn't
say that because i was his wife because
he read [ __ ] and um get rid of that [ __ ]
but honestly he said you know and i take
i listen to my husband a lot and so i i
read it too it's a [ __ ] good book
kelly got a it no
listen right before he gets locked up
you give him a cameo
he could be my first baby daddy
she could be on the audiobook
i did i gotta audio book his alpha is
you can buy that too now
what tier are your next few dates that
you're doing um morty i'm at morty's
august 25th through the 26th
promoting the book
yeah doing signs and taking pictures
yeah showing how beautiful in september
i'm in boston at the boston comedy
festival okay uh i know i'm coming to
cincinnati in november i'm trying to
pull it up lee you can pull it up faster
calm
um
if you're in the indianapolis area
please come out i would love to meet you
if you never heard of me before
she's [ __ ] solid
let me do some
shout outs real quick
alan soraka
colin parker jr jeremy slagoth
i'm coming to tampa cox sucker
gemnin roberto
daniel lolo or something dennis
dumont
tug dakota gilbert
jeff collins
and i don't know what else it says i was
[ __ ] stoned when i wrote this list
don't forget we had the second show on
thursday night in the punchline in san
francisco damn the weekend tickets are
sold out and i don't work on the lord's
day so it's a 10 15 show myself and dean
del rizzi real quick let me talk to you
people about something
i don't know what's going on with your
life you know mr miss pat comes on here
she tells me what's cracker lacking
and listen if you hear the sirens this
is all real we don't [ __ ] around with 3d
all right
and all those sound effects they've been
oh yeah they've been going on [ __ ]
night joey something's been going on
like uh
either isis attacked the airport don't
say that [ __ ] i gotta fly out of here
wednesday
it's a lot of [ __ ] on fire i don't think
isis is attacking burbank airport
what the [ __ ] do you know what do you
swallow me from salami
you don't know what's crazy
dates off real quick did you do what can
i read two or three days off recording
yeah yeah
we
read the next four
because after that you got to assume
that they don't have a pencil and [ __ ]
okay go ahead and [ __ ] suckers really
the next four absolutely
so it's the boston comedy festival
september 21st to the 23rd
and then you're in richmond virginia
october 5th to the 8th
then you're at uh
the joke joint in
houston
october 12th to the 14th
and then you're back in your home state
of oh no never mind
you're about yeah bloomington minnesota
house of comedy
uh mall of america
the 25th to the 29th oh [ __ ] and there's
some more dates coming back in september
they're not on yet but just keep
clicking back misspetcomedy.com
twitter facebook
instagram all of that [ __ ] young people
do
you know man i'm looking at you and i'm
thinking about how uh
how when you put your time in
for years nothing really happens but
when you really put your soul into
something
doors open up and you're the [ __ ]
beautiful example of it
and i wish you all luck in the world
you're beautiful you got a great soul
and you got a great story well thank you
thank you for having me it was my
[ __ ] pleasure you had some [ __ ]
publicists i thought get the [ __ ] out of
here
your business got sucker
shline and kahine he showed up with a
picture of him with a yarmulke get the
[ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
i can't have you talking about about
jewish people i didn't say nothing bad
about him
i just said that he was trying to get to
me
let me wrap this up and we'll get out of
here did you know that depending on
where you get a mortgage you can save
twenty thousand dollars or more but
eighty percent of people
only get one mortgage offer like i did
when i tried to get a house and if you
just go to your bank chances are you'll
get ripped off i mean screwed
lendingtree doesn't want this to happen
here's the thing
the average london tree customer can
save 20 000 over the life of their loan
that's the average
half of these customers could even save
more all right
whether you're looking for a new
mortgage where you want to refinance or
a home equity loan lending tree is the
only place where you get five real
offers from america's top lenders and
you can compare side by side for free
and guess what it only takes three
minutes it's like shopping for flights
online only you're shopping for the best
mortgage
office for you
rates always go up and down but
regardless of what's happening with
rates you can always get the right offer
for you with
lendingtree.com like do me a favor
are you sure you got the best deal find
out how much you can save today at
londontree.com church i don't know if
you're looking for a mortgage i don't
know if you're looking for a house but
if you're looking for one do me a favor
before you do anything before you sign
anything do yourself a favor
and go to
lindentree.com church all right
that's londontree
lendingtree.com
church
london tree llc
nmls
pound 1136
terms and conditions apply
go to lendingtree.com
church number two listen you work hard
all day
you're trying to watch your weight
you don't have time you're trying to
save money
you want to go home at night you really
want to stop at a fast food joint or
some place that serves terrible food and
how long is that going to last for how
long it'll last for all right
this is not good this is where blue
apron comes in
as far as affordable you don't even know
what blue apron is let me tell you
it's the number one fresh ingredient in
recipe delivery service in the country
blue apron's mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everybody even to momo's like myself and
lisa lisayet for example lives off blue
apron me i get it every couple weeks as
filler when mama's not home or something
like that blue apron is tremendous tell
them lee believe it's great it's
delicious it's taught me how to cook i
got my dad on it my dad literally every
single day of the week every month has
blue apron he loves it it's delicious
and listen it's ten dollars per person
per meal
blue apron will deliver seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals variety
forget about it you choose from a
variety of new recipes each week or you
let blue apron's killing every team just
surprise you
i know you love surprises recipes are
not repeated within a year so you'll
never get bored flexible forget about it
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron has
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment
so you only get the deliveries when you
want them each meal comes with a step by
step ready for this one easy to follow
recipe card proportional ingredients and
they can be prepared in 40 minutes or
less you can't lose
you're single whatever you're trying to
lose weight you're trying to eat healthy
this is the way to go plus blue apron's
freshness guarantee promises that every
ingredient in your delivery is ready to
cook or they'll make it right now here's
what i'm gonna do for you check out this
week's menu all right what do you like
this week what did you get lee oh i got
some great stuff i got a steak and
potatoes like steak and like french
fries um potatoes i got uh the chicken
tenders that was really great and i'm
forgetting the third one but it was that
they have so many they have recently
increased the options you have you get
to choose from it's better than ever all
right so check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free
again
you get your first three meals for free
with free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey that's right
three free meals with free shipping by
going to blueapron.com joey you'll love
how it feels and taste and to create
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait
do yourself a favor that's
blueapron.com joey blue apron a better
way to cook again i want to thank blue
apron again i want to thank lending tree
again i want to thank annette but most
importantly i want to thank one of my
favorite guests
because uh when uh she comes on
i get what it's like the rolling it's
like well i'll slide the family stone
you know what i'm saying
i get what the [ __ ] i get
i don't get somebody outside and you
turn into somebody else no not with this
i'm happy about your success god bless
you thank you your daughter is beautiful
you have a beautiful family i read your
little [ __ ] twitters and uh
good luck never mind to me spell words
and i will retweet all your stuff around
book time thank you my word and i make
sure i'm gonna try blue apron because i
can't cook for [ __ ]
and i'm gonna play like i cook let's see
look at blue apron he just look at you
you know what i'm saying that's how good
you're looking
god bless you
knock them down on this tour stop making
me smile jordan please go to the goobies
for the book signing is it my goobies
morty morty's i'm sorry morty mcgoobies
go to morty's it's a great club it is
indianapolis she's going to do it the
25th through the 26th bam there you have
it i love you [ __ ] have a great
weekend love you too [ __ ] we'll
talk to you all right stay black lee who
loves you more than me
nobody [ __ ] bam let's do this
you